what's up everybody Welcome to CES I'm
Brian Tong I'm justini zeric and this is
a very special CES this
year when you think about it how many
people are actually here with us well
we're talking about over
130,000 attendees what 4,000 plus
exhibitors it's wild and there's over
12200 startups and this entire space is
about 30 football fields 30 this is the
tech Mecca the only place you really
want to be if you love this
stuff
welcome to CES
2024 I don't know are you excited about
this there's so much energy here like I
can actually feel
it let's go let's
[Music]
go they finally let me on the show floor
and I could not be more excited because
we're here at the Sony booth and I'm
hanging with Larry now behind me this
was kind of like the hit yesterday at
the Sony presentation because we saw
this ailo car being driven with a Sony
PlayStation controller for presentation
purposes only correct thank you for that
display you're welcome so what have we
got behind us so Sony Honda mobility is
a joint venture of both Sony and Honda
you know that you're going to get a
incredible car that's focused first and
foremost on safety this car is packed
with lar radar and tons of sensors
wrapped all the way around it's taking
the best of both of those companies and
merging them together to be able to
develop this product that's both safe
and also just packed with entertainment
it can give you level three autonomous
driving in certain conditions but
absolutely a minimum of level two plus
what do you do with all that time when
you're not having to hold your hands on
the wheel I can think of a few things
maybe like Somey PlayStation play a
little bit of video games there you go
you do get PlayStation Remote Play so
all you PlayStation 5 fans out there
even outside of that there's also the
element of ride view which is our movie
service so the latest Blockbuster hits
that you may want to watch while you're
on that road trip no this isn't just a
concept like this is actually happening
pre-orders next year and then actually
available in 2026 like if you think
about it that's actually that's very
soon I mean I'm such a Sony fan like I
might have to put in a pre-order you
know I mean how can we say no to
this well this is the most terrifying
thing that I've ever seen here at the
Sony booth now obviously Sony does so
many things from Automotive to TVs to
phones to drones also uh video games
Hello this is a clicker from The Last of
Us and this is the part two remastered
which there's actually some gameplay
here at CES at the booth but we can't
show you yet so I'm excited to get my
hands on that and see how it is but I'm
going to move on because this is
terrifying this is pretty exciting so if
any of you have seen the Grand Turismo
movie This is actually a replica of the
sled that they had in the movie I'm
going to play the game and please no
judgment on my driving skills I'm not
the best driver you can ask me my sister
wow all right here we go here we go here
we
go okay I'm actually not doing that bad
but I don't want to like and this is
what we love about CEs getting hands on
with tech oh oh shoot oh
God okay I can't drive in heels all
right I'm blaming the shoes yeah it's a
it's a whole vibe I think I have a
future in racing oh okay maybe not I
take it back I'm just really glad that
autonomous driving is the thing
now you guys may have seen that the new
PS5 has a new slim version which I'm
obsessed with but they've also got some
new face plate and some new controller
colors so check these out we have got
the beautiful volcanic red the sterling
silver and the cobalt blue and those
controllers are shining shimmering and
Splendid love
[Music]
it all right Sam so we're in the virtual
production Booth this is one of my
favorite places to visit in C it is so
beautiful you guys have got a cou little
upgrades this year what have we got
definitely so we have our caled B series
1.5 and what we're doing here is
actually doing a driving plate using our
latest Verona panels in front we also
partnered up with our friends at SME s
SM o de you should definitely check them
out great team we also partnered up with
our friends at Moses so it's really
exciting to be able to do that on a
small sale like this cuz we're of course
at CS we're have a big Mandalorian stage
can we get set extension on please
magically the rest of the environment
will appear it'll be trackable W no way
that looks so real and now we're going
to animate that background once you get
in the car I can get in the car of
course you can let me get you oh my
goodness what look and you got the door
for me look at this service this is
impressive okay this is cool so where
are we going you are going to take this
magical portal in Los Angeles that takes
you from the mountains to the city in
less than 5 Seconds here we
go this is messing with my mind because
it feels like I'm actually driving but
I'm I'm not
not notice the reflection just follows
every where she's going 3 2 1 and
[Applause]
[Music]
C just just C best come on like this is
like two forces combining we've been all
over the show floor dude it's been such
a busy day so I was mostly doing
interviews today I got a chance to chat
with the CEO of good and what happened
there well I don't know may say that I
could go on the goodye blimp one day so
okay I got to check out the transparent
lgtv cuz I I just had to without it was
it was really cool it was really awesome
also a Samsung's Booth got to go and
look at all their displays there so I
got to like you know have some fun on
the
floor SK Wonderland okay let's we got it
let's let's go check it out this is this
the coolest booth in look at the mini
sphere this is a mini sphere this is so
with like a face this is wild fantastic
Island and for those of you that don't
know SK is the second largest
conglomerate in Korea so you might not
be familiar with them but everything
from memory chips semiconductors mobile
chips with a push towards sustainability
as well yeah what's really cool is all
of these different stations are showing
how these chips are being used for good
and they wanted this booth to be like
kind of showing the optimism of a future
world of where you know there's zero
emissions and sustainability is top of
mind you can feel it like this energy
it's just bright it's fun but I think I
think we want to try this right like
this is a hydrogen powered train um I
don't know I've never seen one before
but we're here at CES so this is what we
do do you think they'll let us ride it
no not think they will let's go okay
let's check it
out hey should we buckle up oh I'm
Already There mama said buckle up this
is going to be fun I don't think it
actually goes that fast oh here we
go oh wo wo does that Tri that's got Tri
my eyes out FK Wonderland Adventure hey
you
match wow cherry blossoms wow this is so
cool
W okay are we good oh no we're going
into the
water SLR luxotica is one of the leading
manufacturers of lenses and frames for
glasses and they have launched a new
brand called Nuance audio and they have
something so incredible I can't wait to
show it to you come on let's go check it
out Theo thank you so much for chatting
with us today I'm so excited to learn
more about the tech built into these
glasses because there's a ton So today
we're here with extic announcing Nuance
audio I mean this is the combination of
eyewear ey care together with Audiology
so we created a product where it's going
to uh basically announce the possibility
for a heing device in a par frame with
invisibility with an amazing technology
with the directionality it's amazing so
the the tech is built into this I'm very
familiar with the rayan meta so was it
kind of something similar to that
exactly I see you've got on I'm obsessed
with those so I feel like this is
something that's more geared towards Mal
to moderate hearing loss correct correct
I mean it's a totally different
technology and two different very
different product addressing also very
different consumer and patient so Nuance
audio is more a medical device helping
people with mild moderate hearing loss
uh getting back in full their hearing so
that is amazing is a medical but we made
also in stylish with three models
different sizes two colors for the
people to look also stylish one I'm mean
having a corrected site and helping
theing device these are actually lighter
than my normal glasses that I wear it's
yeah they're absolutely 100% a very
standard pair of a frame you can put all
the prescription lenses you want on the
weight is the average 40 plus grams of a
normal standard par of glasses now is
this something that's out on the market
now or coming soon it's coming very soon
I mean we're launching in the second
part of the year so where I mean
probably Q4 and it's going to be
available in all the different optomet
oftalmology but also biology that all
the different consumer and PTI are
us think that I can get a demo
absolutely yeah all right let's go check
it out yeah okay we're going to get a
demo and see how this really works okay
so now we will immerse you into the
crowded New York restaurant through this
next
speaker so you will be surrounded by the
noise yep I already can hear it so now a
voice of someone in that noisy
restaurant with you we start talking and
you will try to understand but the
restaurant is noisy so I I can hear them
but well so if you put the glasses on
and you look at the
Target you will
get
voices exactly so Amplified and this
happens only if you look at your target
so if for example you turn your
face you will be in trouble as you were
without the glasses but now I hear you
yeah exactly or you with their loved
ones imers themselves in Social activ
our customers are motivated to find
so through our app you can you can
control the volume of the system it
works also in case you have nearing loss
only in one year uh because the system
will automatically through the
algorithms give you a perfect stereo
effect I feel like this is going help so
we truly believe that this will be the
solution for that 1.2 billion people
affected by mile to moderate loss and
then as soon as I take them off they
turn off to save battery oh my gosh well
thank you so much for sharing
so somebody who actually has mild
hearing loss in one of their ears it has
been such a struggle having
conversations with people so now being
able to wear these I feel like I'm not
going to be left out of conversations
and always saying what what did you say
I can really see how this is going to be
honestly super gamechanging for so many
[Music]
people is anything more CES than to host
in a John Deere tractor I don't think so
I love every year coming and visiting
the John Deere Booth it is always so
much fun yeah you know John Deere a
showcase for technology people don't
think about that rout of the gates but
they've done everything from you know
helping Farmers with autonomous tractors
also their data and their systems just
again pulling all this data together to
make lives more efficient and easier for
well I think you hit the turn signal Ser
something yeah did you do that well then
I better come on let's get in here's get
okay okay see you guys all right see you
all right Maya this looks absolutely
incredible I mean there's a tractor
behind us and this is an Austin Texas
yeah and it's running fully autonomously
so we can control this with the with the
phone yeah you can imagine if you're a
farmer and you step away from the field
you've already given the machine its
instructions it knows what to do maybe
you want to pause it maybe you want to
check on it adjust its speed so you'd be
able to do that today just like you
would if you were on the farm scroll
down and then I can see hey that's where
my tractor is I can see the path that
it's taking in the field I can also
swipe up and if maybe one of you guys
want to interact with it you can tell it
to pause can I yeah go ahead okay feed
is right there so you want to tell it to
go a little faster I do sure how fast
yeah keep cranking it up they're five
we're at five now push it to six go
we're going to six Fast and Furious
Justin Fast and Furious
oh there we go magic the magic number so
now it just went from four to six with
your command this so cool and I can just
completely stop it as well if I wanted
to yeah so go ahead and hit pause pause
there it goes boom and there's a lot of
talk of spatial Computing but how are we
actually going to do that well I think
mudra has cracked the code to that so
what have we got here this little
wearable device this is the first time
we are able to sell the mudra ban to the
public it is a revolutionary product 9
years in development for reading neural
signals through the wrist available now
for sale that's amazing and I love when
you see something at CES that's actually
available now so can we get a demo to
see how it actually works absolutely
okay we have ohde showing you motion
with his fingers he is showing you the
actual neurological signal generated by
his finger moving in that direction if
you can map each signal to a command
then you can control pretty much
anything so if this signal becomes turn
on my lights this signal becomes turn on
the dishwasher you can just imagine
where it will take you he's turning now
on air mouse capabilities w we have a
six degree of Freedom IMU which allows
you to come to take any interface and
control it as if you were using an air
mouse this is so cool look at this get
no
squished we feel that you leave your
house every day with these two attached
to your to your body so why not use them
with you why carry an extra device we
attach right to the Apple watch you're
wearing a band anyway that does nothing
might as well let it do something and I
think even for accessibility like this
is changing the game for so many people
who may have you know different
abilities and this can actually help I'm
about to blow your mind okay great if I
chopped my hand off the signal could
still be R wow oh my I don't even know
I'm speechless like can we show you one
more demo yes he's going to play O to
Joy for you right now
[Music]
okay I don't even know what to say I'm
not even sure what's going on right now
this is incredible so it is for sale how
much is it $349 there is a show special
but you have to be at the show to scan
that QR code well guess who's at the
show I'm at the
show we are at insta 360 and this is one
of my favorite small portable action
camera companies now their name is insta
360 they've got a lot of 360 cameras but
actually their newest camera is this one
this is the Ace Pro and this one's kind
of interesting because it is
co-engineered with Lega and it shoots up
to 8K and I love that it has this little
flip up screen so you're able to
actually see what you're filming so they
have a whole magnetic mounting system
that makes it super easy to just
magnetically attach this to different
accessories and of course they've got
their insta 360 selfie stick we have got
the insta 360 go now they have the new
go 3 that just came out now the original
one was this white one but they just
came out with a matte black which is so
beautiful so the little tiny camera is
is inside of this little housing you can
just pop this right off and you can
mount it places it has a little magnetic
backing to it and they have all these
really fun accessories this is my
favorite accessory though okay
everything's like mounted down so so you
don't run off with it here at the show
floor but this is a little necklace
Mount so you can wear it around your
neck and you can wear it basically right
here to get really cool first person
action shots
and if you want you can use this as kind
of like a little remote there I am and
it is cool because you can shoot in
either vertical or horizontal so
depending upon how you have this framed
it'll automatically adjust so this is
the insta 360 flow this thing is so fun
and what I love about it is it's so
small it's portable it's compact it also
does have a little extender if you do
want to make the selfie stick a little
bit longer the tracking is something
that I'm obsessed with as a sometimes
solo Creator I'm able to Trace myself
and it'll keep me in the
frame look at that oh there you are so I
know I keep saying insta 360 we're
finally going to get to a 360 camera
come see it and here it is finally beget
to the 360 camera this is the insta 360
X3 and with this you're able to shoot
really incredible 360 video but why I
love this I could be filming the back I
could be filming the front so you can
basically reframe anything that you want
but this is
hi Michael hello how are you I heard a
rumor you might be coming by and I made
something very special for you you want
to see it yes hang on one
second oh my good is this a lifesize in
this is a life-size X3 camera and and
guess what what might be your next
Halloween costume you want to try it on
wa this is a costume you can put this
thing
on would you like to be an X3 for a
minute honestly that is a dream come
true let's see how you look at it all
right let's do it so what I just put it
on okay here we
go I hope I fit okay I fit all right now
put your arms out okay okay all right to
hand you a smaller X3 on a gigantic
selfie stick
okay okay how do you feel good go ahead
can you hold my hand okay one more step
all right this is everything CES where
dreams come
true oh my go this is the Happ EST
moment of my life okay I will send you
this version a new one to your to your
uh to your house okay thank
you she's back everyone Round of
Applause
everybody Justine it was such a pleasure
oh my gosh thank you for making my
dreams come true thank you so much thank
you appreciate you oh so good I'm so
happy we are now with Gucci from DTA and
there is something under this massive
cloth yeah what's under here I mean
we're used to unboxing but can we do was
it unveilings yeah for sure should we do
it okay all right all right do you want
to take one side right three two
one
W ladies first
shotty all right W okay got my leg over
here what okay this is sick do you need
a license for this uh it could depend on
the estate you want to fly in actually
but the machine is totally able to fly
by its own so is this a touch
yeah hey Gucci can you tell us about
some of the technology here we see a is
it an eight propeller system eight
propellers eight Motors eight batteries
and one parachute with a rocket actually
on it wait what you said one parachute
is one parachute for the war machine
meaning that if something happens not
for us like who's going to who's going
to share yeah one parachute for the
machine that that's that's you just have
to cool that and the parachute will will
deploy and the war machine will land
safely actually and we talk about like
kind of safety aspects like comparing
this to other types of I guess flying
vehicles I mean cuz this is a little bit
different than anything I've ever seen
there are eight pedos so it can fly on
five so meaning that you can lose three
pedos and in case of you lose two twoo
much P then you just pull and you you've
got the parachute so in terms of safety
I don't know something that is the same
in
in what have you learned you know
through taking this up in the air what
are some of the learnings you guys just
it's the first time you don't pilot your
airplane actually because if you want to
move forward you move and if if you let
everything the machine stops in the
three dimensions and it waits if you try
to fly an helicopter that won't happen
it it hovers in place when you don't do
it you're is this available now like
what's the availability like it will be
delivered in 2026 and we we are sending
three orders right now J let's let's
just go all right he's gone so I'm going
to be on my best behavior yeah's go dude
this is sick hit it
[Music]
our CES experience is coming to an end
I'm so sad I am too oh my gosh don't
worry because you guys can relive all of
the great conversations and
presentations over at c. Tech and also a
huge big thank you to CTA for all their
support as well as our amazing crew out
here really helping us capture this
entire CES experience we'll see you guys
next year later woo let's come on we
let's get a little clap in here yeah
yeah I'm Happ for you we can put some
sound effects in there to make it BR
audio all cricket sound
effects